Secretary of State Rex Tillerson will
meet with foreign leaders next month in
a show of solidarity against North
Korea's nuclear program our serious
issues that matter this morning looks at
the tensions between the u.s. and North
Korea the standoff is one of president
Trump's biggest challenges overseas
North Korea fired a missile into the Sea
of Japan last night things have reached
a rather dangerous level following the
tragic death of otto warmbier the trump
administration is considering a ban on
American travel to North Korea do you
believe the North Koreans should be held
responsible for his death Kesava yes Kim
jong-un celebrated what would be
Pyongyang first ICBM test they will be
met with fire and fury like the world
has never seen
Rocket Man is on a suicide mission for
himself and for his regime north korea
has declared that it has completed its
nuclear weapons program it claims the
rocket is capable of striking the entire
mainland United States where are we with
North Korea right now well we're getting
close to a military conflict we're
running out of time America and its
allies will take all necessary steps to
achieve a denuclearization and ensure
that this regime cannot threaten the
world
CBS knows senior national security
contributor Michael Morell was acting
and deputy director of the CIA he is
host of the intelligence matters podcast
New Yorker staff writer Evan Osnos
traveled to North Korea on assignment
for the magazine and he made it back
safely to the table we're very glad
about that your article is very
harrowing to read a couple of in a
couple of places but let's start with
you Mike because President Trump has
told aides that he will be handily
judged by how he handles North Korea do
you think as tough talk helps Rocketman
locked and loaded fury like you've never
seen is that helpful to this
conversation I think if you're going to
make a threat right if you're gonna say
that if you don't give up your nuclear
program that we are going to take
military action that you have better
already decided that you're going to do
that because if North Korea doesn't
blink and they move forward and you end
up doing nothing right you've lost a
tremendous amount of credibility and I
think that the language in that respect
is dangerous does anybody think North
Korea is going to blink I don't think so
I think this this program is incredibly
important to him from a security
perspective and from a political
perspective he's not going to stop until
he has demonstrated the capability of
putting a US city at risk of a nuclear
attack and Evon we know that a UN under
secretary mr. Feldman has been in North
Korea
laid out a couple of different proposals
essentially talks right the South
Koreans the president told me he wants
bilateral talks the North Koreans now
are saying no we're not we're interested
in going that which suggests that there
are just more missile tests ahead
correct
the North Koreans right now actually
feel like they're in a pretty good place
you know they've been able to steadily
advance the progress of this program to
their desired objective and what is
their objective it's what Michael
mentioned it's the idea that they could
actually hit an American city they're
not there yet best assessments are they
could be there within a year but their
goal is to put off the negotiations long
enough so that they're in the best
possible position and then get to the
table have a new right that to go
between Washington and Pyongyang at this
nuclear moment is to be struck most of
all by how little that to understand
each other
that's pretty discouraging yeah I have
to tell you that was one of the
surprises for me we've got incredibly
smart people in our country working on
North Korea all the time and the reality
is that North Korea is enveloped in a
kind of fog that's actually the term
they use Kim jong-il said we should
surround ourselves make ourselves
impenetrable to the outside world and to
some degree they've succeeded and one of
the ways we can cut through that would
be to have greater diplomatic contacts
some sort of dialogue James clapper
former Director of National Intelligence
says if we don't have any sort of
conversation going we are in fact flying
blind it's in our advantage you also
write of them that between the two
leaders between Kim jong-un and
President Trump there are only seven
years of political experience and that
you're dealing with two very volatile
personalities but it's interesting to
hear North Koreans view of Americans and
President Trump what did you learn about
that and when I was in Pyongyang and I
was with some foreign ministry officials
whose job it is is to read Donald
Trump's Twitter feed listen to his
speeches try to analyze the American
government and what they said was
frankly we're mystified we can't figure
out if he is as they put it irrational
or whether he's proceeding down a subtle
strategy that's leading them to an
objective so when we send mixed messages
when we send confusing messages they're
not quite sure what to make of it
Michael one of the interesting things -
as you try and contain North Korea some
way and and increase sanctions the
Russians have actually increased their
trade with North Korea in fact shipping
over enough oil that the price of oil
has gone down in North Korea and I asked
that president's national security about
that advisor about that yesterday has
President Trump asked President Putin to
stop those oil shipments what is Russia
doing Russia's strategy globally is to
undermine the United States wherever it
can so Russia's Russia's interest here
is to make just simply make our life
more difficult make it more likely that
we will not be successful in North Korea
that's what Vladimir Putin is trying to
do so what is Kim's endgame here if you
ask people in Pyongyang really cut
through what it is that they're trying
to achieve the thing they return to over
and over again is they want to avoid
being Saddam Hussein or Muammar Qaddafi
two leaders who were developing nuclear
weapons gave them up at a certain point
and then were ultimately were vulnerable
to American pressure but do you think
it's just that determined to act or does
he want to have nuclear capability to
become an increasing
bully around the world yeah so there's
there's there's two reasons that
everybody agrees with right one is he
wants them to deter us from attacking
him right and he needs them politically
at home because he has told his people
were under threat from the United States
this is the way to protect ourselves
this is going to be my legacy to you
right so it's important politically the
one possibility that people are just
starting to discuss is does he want
these weapons to try to coerce the
United States in South Korea so in other
words once he has them
will he be more aggressive on the Korean
Peninsula and the question is how do you
determine that and that's more difficult
is there a viable military option that
is not catastrophic so I don't believe
so
and it's not viable from two
perspectives one is I don't think
there's a military option that can
achieve the president's objective of
destroying all the nuclear weapons and
all the missiles there simply can't get
to them all for reasons I can't talk
about right the other is there's not a
military option that I know of that
doesn't have a high likelihood of
resulting in a second Korean War
possible and missile attacks on Guam and
Japan and possibly even missile attacks
in the United States of America buteven
they seem prepared for catastrophe that
one military guy you were walking around
with said push us push us hard we will
not die alone that it is very scary it's
very much part of their self-image they
see themselves as survivors all right
Evan and Michael always good to see you
because you guys at our table